Un de mes pédagogues favoris, l'auteur et universitaire brésilien Paulo Freire,
parle avec éloquence du fait que l'éducation doit servir
à éveiller l'esprit critique, le sentiment d'appartenance à l'humanité.
Dans son ouvrage le plus célèbre, « Pédagogie des opprimés »,
il déclare que « personne ne peut être véritablement humain
s'il refuse l'humanité aux autres. »
J'ai beaucoup réfléchi à ça dernièrement, à cette idée de l'humanité,
et surtout, à la question de savoir qui dans ce monde a le privilège
d'être perçu comme un humain à part entière.
Au cours des derniers mois,
le monde a vu des hommes et femmes noirs non armés
se faire tuer par des policiers ou des justiciers.
Ces événements et tout ce qui s'en est suivi
m'ont ramené à ma propre enfance
et aux décisions que mes parents ont prises pour élever un jeune noir aux USA.
Des décisions qu'enfant, je ne comprenais pas toujours aussi bien qu'aujourd'hui.
Ça a dû être si difficile pour eux, ils devaient trouver ça tellement injuste
de devoir me priver d'une partie de mon enfance
juste pour que je puisse rentrer sain et sauf le soir.
Par exemple, je me rappelle d'un soir,
j'avais environ 12 ans, lors d'une excursion dans une autre ville,
mes amis et moi avions acheté des pistolets à eau.
Nous avions transformé le parking de l'hôtel en un champ de bataille.
On se cachait derrière des voitures,
on courait dans l'ombre, entre les lampadaires.
Les rires résonnaient partout sur le parking.
Mais en moins de 10 minutes,
mon père est sorti, m'a pris par le bras
et m'a ramené dans la chambre avec une poigne inhabituelle.
Avant que je puisse ouvrir la bouche,
et lui dire à quel point il m'avait ridiculisé devant mes amis,
il m'a reproché d'être aussi naïf.
Il m'a regardé dans les yeux, la peur se lisait sur son visage,
et m'a dit : « Je suis désolé, mon fils,
mais tu ne peux pas jouer comme tes amis blancs.
Tu ne peux pas faire semblant de tirer avec une arme.
Tu ne peux pas courir dans l'obscurité.
Tu ne peux pas te cacher ailleurs que derrière tes dents. »
Je comprends aujourd'hui à quel point il a dû être effrayé,
j'aurais pu disparaître si facilement dans la nuit,
si un homme avait confondu l'eau avec autre chose,
trouvant ainsi une bonne raison d'intervenir.
C'est le genre de messages qui m'ont suivi toute ma vie :
mets toujours tes mains en évidence, ne fais pas de gestes brusques,
enlève ta capuche quand le soleil se couche.
Mes parents nous ont élevés dans une armure de conseils,
dans un océan d'alarmes, pour que personne ne nous empêche de respirer,
et ne nous transforme en souvenir.
Pour qu'on soit des enfants, et non des cercueils ou du béton.
Pas pour qu'on soit meilleurs que les autres,
mais simplement pour nous garder en vie.
Tous mes amis noirs ont reçu le même message,
le « discours », dès qu'on était assez grands
pour être confondus avec un clou prêt à être aplati au sol,
dès que notre couleur de peau devenait quelque chose dont il fallait avoir peur.
Mais qu'est-ce que ça fait à un enfant
de grandir en sachant qu'il ne peut pas agir comme un enfant ?
Que les caprices de l'adolescence sont trop dangereux pour lui,
qu'il ne peut pas même être curieux,
qu'il n'a pas le droit à l'erreur,
que les préjugés de quelqu'un
peuvent mettre fin à sa vie.
Mais ça ne doit pas nous définir.
Parce que nos parents nous ont fait comprendre
que nos corps ne servent pas à recevoir des balles,
mais à faire du cerf-volant, de la corde à sauter et à rire jusqu'à avoir mal.
À l'école, on nous a appris à lever la main,
mais pas seulement pour nous rendre,
et que la seule chose à abandonner
est l'idée que nous ne méritons pas notre place.
On dit que la vie des noirs compte, pas parce que les autres ne comptent pas,
mais pour affirmer qu'on a le droit de vivre sans crainte,
même si les faits disent le contraire.
Je veux vivre dans un monde où mon fils
ne sera pas présumé coupable dès sa naissance,
où le jouet dans sa main ne sera pas confondu avec autre chose qu'un jouet.
Et je refuse d'accepter que construire ce nouveau monde soit impossible,
un monde où le nom d'un enfant
n'est pas écrit sur un t-shirt, ou sur une tombe,
où la valeur d'une vie
n'est déterminée que par le fait d'avoir des poumons,
un monde où chacun d'entre nous peut respirer.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)